beautiful day let's acknowledge my girl
today I just want to get more insight
into his life
well you're about to get it because
Peter Webber's ex-girlfriend is speaking
out I am crazy for Hannah the way I feel
what there no one's ever made me feel
not even close
fans of The Bachelorette have watched
this season's front runner have some
pretty serious combos with Hannah Brown
about what he said was heartbreak over
his last relationship I have not felt
like this truly happy I do see a future
now his ex model Kaylee Lutz is telling
e.t.a her side of the story claiming he
suddenly ended their relationship in
December to appear on the hit ABC show
after five months of dating quote we
were very serious he told me he loved me
for the first time in October and we
talked almost every time we saw each
other about how we were going to make it
last long-term the two dated
long-distance after meeting on a dating
app in June of 2018 she lived in Atlanta
while Peter lives in LA whoa we were
crazy about each other even though we
lived on opposite sides of the country
we saw each other often it was as easy
as a long-distance relationship could be
when I commit like I'm there you know I
am all-in
Kaley says the two met each other's
families early on went on vacations
together and even talked about moving in
but in December things took a quick turn
when she says he ended their
relationship over FaceTime two days
before Christmas she explained quote he
didn't really have a reason why I was
devastated and completely blindsided I'm
not one of those guys that's been
involved with all the drama the model
says that's when she noticed that a
bachelorette producer had recently
followed him on Instagram and she
claimed he erased any trace of her on
social media I'm looking for a co-pilot
for life quote he definitely didn't go
on the show for the right reasons I
believe he went on it for the chance at
Fame and he got what he wanted I am
falling so freakin fast for Hannah as
for those fans who want Peter to be the
next Bachelor
well Kaylie says that would quote be a
huge mistake I'm ready you know adding I
would hate to see him hurt more people
[Music]